one of the companies i co-founded is a
company called space adventures and we
are the only company to date to have
flown people privately to space we have
flown eight passengers to the space
station going up on the saw use dennis
tito was our first richard garriott
who's the chairman of space adventures
in a trustee of the XPrize foundation
for second generation astronaut and our
latest was Gila liberty the founder and
CEO of Cirque de Soleil these people
spend about 45 million dollars to go up
for 10 days to the space station
incredible experience if we could buy a
seat on the shuttle which we cannot the
cost per seat probably 100 million
dollars in the shuttle so the cell uses
is somewhat somewhat cheaper if you went
uh and we had a super efficient system
the cost I think you'd ever the closest
you'll ever get down is probably in the
four or five million dollars per seat
using existing propulsion systems if
you're whole system was reusable and if
you flew it on a very frequent basis but
if you go and you do the energy
calculations of how much it cost to put
you and your space hood orbit you know
high school physics student can do this
it's easy its mass times gravity times
height to get your potential energy and
then one-half MV squared to get your
kinetic energy and if you do that for
you and you're in a 200 kilograms space
suit turns out the total energy spent
over an hour is about 1.6 giga joules
and if you bought this off the electric
grid at seven cents a kilowatt hour the
cost of getting you and your spacesuit
into orbit is about 120 bucks so the
price improvement curve ahead of us is
45 million to one hundred bucks that's a
pretty big motivation
I'm not naive enough to think that we're
not going to have amazing physics
breakthroughs I mean technologically
we've been a technological species for a
hundred or two hundred years depending
on where you you measure that so I think
there is much we do not know but in the
near term I'm betting on a technology
which i think is very doable today in
fact I'm in the middle of talking with a
number of benefactors about creating an
X Prize around this concept it's called
beamed power propulsion and the concept
is today rockets haven't changed in the
last 2,000 years since early Chinese
rocket r you have a tube you burn
something inside and the hot gases come
out when n that's you know they've
gotten bigger more expensive more
elaborate more efficient but there's
still the same basic concepts so one of
the XPrize ideas and I'm excited about
that I really want to have is called
beam power propulsion the way it works
is you have a source of energy in the
ground either lasers or probably
microwaves and that system is getting
more and more efficient every year the
price to generate a mega watt or
gigawatt of energies coming down year
after year we're learning how to print
it make it more efficient and what you
do is you beam the energy to the rocket
and the rocket basically converts that
energy to heat and heats up a working
fluid like hydrogen and then the
hydrogen goes out the other end that can
reduce the cost of spaceflight by 50 to
100 fold and its technology that could
be done right now but no one's doing it
because no one's doing it and that's
when X PRIZE really comes in if you can
demonstrate something just enough like
for example with the original ansari x
prize for spaceflight we demonstrated a
ship carrying three people up 200
kilometers twice in two days and then
richard branson comes in and you know
says i commit a quarter of a billion
dollars to commercialize that technology
so i'd love to demonstrate beam power
propulsion and once that's demonstrate
enough then new technology will come in
every prize that we design has to meet
certain attributes number one clear and
measurable three people 100 kilometers
100 mile per gallon or its equivalent
car you know with experimental hundred
human genomes in 10 days the second
thing is it has to be addressing a grand
challenge it has to be something which
could have a paradigm change on the
backend the third is if it's properly
designed when it's one the world is
paying attention and it ignites a new
industry for me the fact that branson
was there committing the money and all
of a sudden people started buying
tickets you know they've been over a
thousand tickets sold to fly into space
was what made this really exciting yes
spaceship one is hanging in the air and
space museum right above Apollo 11 next
to spirit of st. Louis that's great but
the fact that we have an industry going
is what makes it awesome so other thing
is I'm looking for prizes or winnable in
three two eight years in X prizes if
it's less than three years was too easy
more than eight years no one gives a
anymore the other thing though is
we are now creating something we call X
challenges x prizes are these bigger ten
million dollars or more the x challenges
our million dollar level prizes that are
more winnable in a year or two years or
about moving technology forward in a
demonstratable fashion